now it's been a year since journalist
Jamarcus Shoji entered Saudi Arabia's
consulate in Istanbul to get documents
he needed for his upcoming marriage he
never came out investigations by Turkish
officials indicate that shotty was
killed and dismembered by a Saudi hit
squad Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman says he takes responsibility but
he denies ordering the killing kesaji
fiance is demanding answers from Riyadh
and the Crown Prince money doesn't come
it is meaningful that this was broadcast
close to the October 2nd date it sounds
to me like it was something that was
said to weaken or lessen public pressure
secondly if that is not the case and it
was carried out under the crown prince's
responsibility then we would have the
right to ask him about the details then
why was Jamal killed and why has the
public not been informed about the death
until now I am talking about the details
for instance we don't know where the
body is his funeral prayers have not
been performed there is no burial if he
carries full responsibility then I
believe we should be able to ask these
questions in that case Mohammed bin
Salman should give an answer from the
good Andrew Simmons our correspondent
who's outside the public prosecutor's
office in Istanbul we've also got
tomorrow honest al he's outside the
consulate itself the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul and jamala calls this is where
the crime took place many people and
many groups now determined that this
crime will not be forgotten
they are indeed and now they're coming
to organize a memorial service martín
which they're calling a moment of
unsilenced in it they're trying to
essentially sense a defined message that
not only will this crime not be
forgotten but they will continue to call
for justice
to be delivered in order for those the
perpetrators of this murder to be held
accountable but also to get answers to
questions that remain unanswered like
where are the remains of Jamal
Specialties body but also to call for
protection of other journalists
particularly in a region that is
releasing a lot of oppression and
crackdown on a free press and that is
one of the messages that Jamal Ashok G
is legacy is based on it is that free
press and the need for there to be
people who speak truth to power aside
from this memorial service which will
have speakers including human rights
activists including friends and
colleagues of tomorrow photography as
well as other figures like the Nobel
Prize winner Tawakkol Karman from Yemen
and others there will also be an
unveiling of a memorial stone in this
green square which is just in front of
the consulates and that's significant
for a number of reasons firstly
obviously it is at least a place to
remember and pay respects to Jamal
officially the last place where he was
seen alive as he was entering that
building particularly as there is no
grave for him because we don't know
where the remains are but also it is an
insistence from his friends loved ones
and those who want to continue in his
footsteps that there is a physical
reminder of the slain journalist
considering that the Saudi authorities
there are reports that they have sold
the consulate building behind us so its
future is still unclear so that is
what's going to take place today no
doubt there will be a remember a call
once again that justice must be
delivered and those who are responsible
for the murder of the militia regime
must be held accountable all right Jamal
thank you for that let's go to Andrew
now Andrew Simmons is outside the public
prosecutor's office
Andrews so many questions remain
unanswered we've seen the fiance
directing her questions specifically at
reared and at the crown prince himself
what are the Turkish authorities likely
to do to follow up on those I think
there's a lot of sympathy for her
teacher chingy's view expressed there
earlier because there is a solemn
atmosphere obviously seven kilometers
away where jamal is right now in front
of the consulate here at the court
complex this houses the prosecutor
general's office and his colleagues his
prosecutors who've been working flat out
during this past year with preparation
for indictments for the suspects there
are 15 here in Turkey on the list and
another three an advanced team that went
to Riyadh and then back in preparation
for this crime a lot of the attention
recently has been focused on what
preparations were made clear evidence in
leaked phone conversations that there
was a state organized plan as soon as ji
maharaj ji' went into that consulate on
october on September the 28th and then
returned rocked over the second in this
gap between that a massive operation had
been planned
when I say massive I don't necessarily
mean on the ground but in Riyadh at
state level with Saud al Kitani a close
adviser to Mohammed bin Salman actually
organizing things he's not been seen for
many months
it's thought it's rumored rather that
he's being killed poisoned to death that
was that a state murder if it did indeed
take place could this be following a
pattern where people inside Saudi
influential people in inside Saudi who
may have evidence on the one things are
eliminated that's unclear but as far as
the investigation goes it is complete it
does in the views of the prosecutors
here a conclude that there was a murder
and those murder charges could be
directed at 15 people or at least some
them in particular there is an
indictment we know on maja Abdul Azeez
Matt Reb who was the leader on the
ground now this man who was a close
advisor not advisor a close aide to
Mohammed bin Salman and his former
bodyguard very deep in the intelligence
world and the intelligence world now has
kicked back with all the evidence tapes
bugged tapes spyware in phones you've
heard it all more or less spread out
over a year and it's conclusive what
happened and what was organized despite
all the attempts by Saudi Arabia to
cover this crime up and also one
important factor and that's the court
case or what is described by many
observers as a secret operation really
to cover things up that court case has
11 people on the indictment list and
five facing the death penalty and the
lot goes to say for wait and watch now
Turkey isn't so hopeful there can be an
extradition or any international inquiry
agnes calamar wants that international
inquiry and wants justice done she
believes that Mohammed bin Salman is
responsible but where do we go from here
the fear is nowhere in terms of
international justice